can we stick on the
camus absurdism versus existentialism
sure
what do you think is the difference in
your ideas about
anarchism too it seems like those are
somehow intricately connected because uh
existentialism is connected to freedom
and freedom is connected to anarchism
sure but i mean
sartre was a defender of the soviet
union
uh he said explicitly about things like
gulags like even if it's true we
shouldn't talk about it
um so he it's what people don't
appreciate is how
uh human beings can have contradictory
ideas in their minds at the same time
so one would think okay someone's a
democrat they think abc therefore they
think def
people that have all sorts of
contradictions and it's not at all clear
and they'll have a clean conscience
because the human mind is very
sophisticated
um and is capable of doing this so
sartre
you know was you would think he's this
radical individualist you know this
sense of ultimate freedom
but he's defending the soviet union uh
camus on the other hand would probably
be
it was very much like a social democrat
he didn't really talk about
what politics should be so much as it
shouldn't be his essay
reflections on the guillotine is one of
the great masterpieces of all time
an attack on the death penalty not in
terms of
no one's evil or it's wrong to kill
murderers but in terms of
what does it do for a society if you
have someone who set takes a person
and locks them in a room and says you
know in two years i'm going to murder
you
and you lock them for that this is not
someone we regard as moral regardless as
someone who's
a complete monster but that's what the
state does you know
with the death penalty and he challenges
us to think
is this the kind of people we want to be
do and again he's saying i'm not saying
killing a murderer is wrong i'm not
saying evil is wrong his entire career
was dedicated to fighting the concept of
evil but
are we the kind of people who want to be
doing
these things that in any other context
we regard as torture
or depraved so i'm much more of a camus
person
than a star trek he was probably against
war in that same way so i don't i have
to
uh admit i don't know much about the
political side of kamu
well and i don't think his political
side's that interesting or relevant what
i find
so interrupted what i find fascinating
about camus and what i think about on a
daily basis from him
is his insistence that you have to live
a life based on conscience
that you have to be accountable to
yourself when you put your pill your
head on the pill
at the end of the day and ask yourself
did i live
a righteous life with integrity true to
my values
did i uh not needlessly cause harm to
innocent people
um you know that kind of mindset did i
if someone is weak
am i using that as an opportunity to
exploit them or to harm them
or do i feel a bit of sympathy or
empathy for this person
because maybe they didn't have
circumstances that were you know as
beneficial as other people had well how
does that fit absurdism
where everything is absurd nothing has
meaning
uh you know it really borders on
nihilism so he
his he regards not his his philosophy
explicitly said is a response to
nihilism and
a uh attack on nihilism he you know he
regrets cynicism as like
the worst value people can have and i
agree with him
100 percent a lot of times people call
me cynical online
and i push back very very hard because
to be a si
you know i had this quote and then you
write where i say i'd rather be naive
than a cynic
because a cynic is a hopeless man who
projects his hopelessness to the world
at large
uh kamu this is the metaphor i use and i
find it very inspirational
i thought it was in his work but i guess
i thought if i described it to him
there's two types of people you imagine
you go to a mountainside
and you see a blank canvas
on an easel standing in front of this
mountainside
one people be like why is this blank
canvas here
you know what what was this what's going
on here and just be confused
whereas the other type of person will be
like there's a blank canvas here
in this beautiful countryside what a
great opportunity
i can paint this river i could paint
that bird i could paint my friends or
myself
in the background infinite choices and
this is a gift that i have been given
and i think that also ties very heavily
into what i was i went to yeshiva as a
kid which is jewish school
what we were taught in incessantly how
to look at life is this
beautiful gift that god has given you
and that god wants you to be happy
he wants you to live to the fullest in a
moral way
i remember the first time i went into a
church
and they were asking questions about the
jewish concept the afterlife they
weren't familiar with jewish thought
and it took me a second because i didn't
really have answers and then i
remembered what we were taught which is
let's suppose you're at this banquet
with the best chef on earth
and the table's so heavy because you've
got steaks and you've got chicken and
you've got sushi
and the wine's flowing and you've got
your dr pepper and
mr and mr pibb and the store brand
everything you want
and you're looking around at this
amazing bounty right
and then you turn to this best chef on
earth and you're like oh so what's for
dessert
i mean the offensiveness of that is just
so
you know insane like you have this eat
the meal like i promise you
if i could deliver this meal the
dessert's gonna be okay
so this focus on the afterlife when
we've been given this amazing gift
uh you know on this earth is is a very
kind of different mindset from both
the jewish tradition as i'd been taught
and the camus mindset
obviously kamu is an atheist didn't
believe in an afterlife but this concept
that life
is is meaningless but that means
you have that opportunity to find value
to seek for truth to seek for happiness
you